in the great scattering which took place
after the death of the worm god-emperor
the bene Jesuit sisterhood sent out
several colonisation teams of their own
to explore the further reaches of space
these groups were never heard from again
fifteen hundred years after the
scattering it was discovered that some
did in fact survived and thrived in
great numbers and power but they were no
longer like the sisters of the old
Empire the scattering brought the
necessity for key changes in their
beliefs
objectives and customs the waves of the
fish speakers the servants of the god
emperor have mingled with the ways of
the Bene jesuit creating the honored
montrezl though many of the many jesuit
waves remained to the honored morees
they also possess outside ideologies and
philosophies that make them
significantly different from their
ancestral origins while the Bene
Gesserit sisterhood used subtle and
deceptive methods to retain and maintain
their power within an existing balance
of power the montrezl sought absolute
domination of all other groups as such
their strategy required either the
enslavement or the destruction of all
other power brokers this also demanded
that the matras possessed powerful
control mechanisms
the most effective method used by the
honored montrezl to infiltrate and
overwhelm other groups was a form of
sexual enslavement during their
evolution in uncharted space they
perfected sexual intercourse into a
narcotic process by using carefully
crafted skills and honored mantra
learned how to coerce an outsider
typically a male into total subservience
this action performed often and upon the
right individuals allowed them to
conquer many other groups in the
scattering as a result they were able to
build a formidable resource and military
base in god emperor of dune the worm god
emperor mentions that his fish speakers
bind males to them this is more evidence
that the mantras are indeed descended in
part from the fish speakers
my Horry often submit to a form of rape
at first only to convert this into a
deep and binding mutual dependence damn
it you're binding Duncan binding with
both the fish speakers and the honored
montrezl Frank Herbert could also be
representing the literary archetype of
the temptress which is characterized by
a sensuous and beautiful woman with the
Mint's provocative charm who ultimately
brings about the downfall of a man
another example of this archetype would
be the mythological sirens the hunger
for intimidation and violence encompass
the entire culture of the honoured Motte
race
this was evident in their frequent use
of assassination to gain power
one member known as the Great honored ma
Trey maintained absolute control of the
group this member typically rose to the
top by killing the previous leader
this was their established Rite of
Ascension and for this reason the title
of leader changed often and loyalty
between the matras was questionable and
certainly conditional at best it is not
revealed in the original six novels
exactly why the honored MA Trey's fled
back into the old Empire only that they
were fleeing a great enemy in the
extended dune universe by Kevin J
Anderson and Bryan Herbert marbella a
been a Jesuit Reverend Mother who was
formerly an honored montre witnesses
within her genetic memory the first
encounter that the matras had with this
unknown enemy the honored matras invaded
the remnants of the Machine Empire and
the retribution of the thinking machines
had been exquisite especially when they
realized that human still existed they
unleashed the scourge a retrovirus which
resided in the victims liver and was
extremely difficult to locate and treat
the virus had a mortality rate of 43
percent the remnants of the destroyed
honored montre Empire returned to the
old Empire seeking many Jesuit skills
and knowledge such as cellular control
which would render the scourge powerless
to gain such knowledge the mot rays
would lead a violent assault on the many
Jesuit strongholds of the old Empire in
the original six novels though most of
the groups of the old Empire were
conquered or infiltrated by the honoured
matras the Benin Jesuit held up a strong
resistance they were of course immune to
the honor montrezl skills of sexual
control with the help of a tradies
descended my leg and their own duncan
idaho gola the Bene jesuit held up
against the honoured montrezl until the
groups eventually were united at the end
of chapter house
you
[Music]
you